e
e e
good morning and welcome to the
reconvened uh conference committee on
house bill
1278 um I happy that everybody is back
together today um hopefully we all are
solemnly remembering that this is the
80th anniversary of D-Day uh so now we
can get down to business and um our the
request from the house is for the Senate
to reede from their Amendment and exceed
to the house
position uh thank you madam chair so in
light of the fact that um there's been
an agreement on Senate Bill 499 that uh
I think confrey signed off on except for
except Senator Bradley hasn't signed off
yet but I'm going to oh great okay you
you heard it here I think we can AED to
the house position so okay thank you
I'll make that
motion thank you is there a second
second thank you and and we all in favor
I I any
opposed and house confies do you uh
agree to put this on
consent yes can you do that the house
can no I don't think we can but okay so
the house will put this on consent thank
you very much I will get this filed so
that we can get it before the rush later
on today thank you so much and I
appreciate you all and with that we'll
close the conference committee on
e
e e
we will open the committee of conference
on House Bill
1593 I'd like to
begin with a memory the very first bill
that I ever introduced in the Senate
Senator Bradley was on the committee and
I wasn't prepared for his first question
which was tell us the process by which
the bill came before the Senate and I
thought Senator Bradley is a smart guy
and pretty experienced and he doesn't
know the process so I asked him to
clarify and he said no what happened in
the policy committee what was the vote
then what happened on the house floor
was it a consent bill or not and I saw
then thank you the value of getting that
on the record I would like to ask the
same question with this proposal how it
came before us
today much uh Mr chair I guess
turnaround is fair play right I've
waited years for it thank
you all right so
um is a long story but I'll try to make
it as brief as possible the existing met
dish settlement between the hospitals in
the state of New Hampshire expires at
the end of this fiscal year so there was
always need for legislation
so several of us um in the Senate
started early on maybe in November or
December I think the three of us um
having discussions about
it um in January Governor sonunu
suggested that um it really should run
through the attorney General's office we
agreed and we waited
for um that process
to um unfold it took a little bit longer
than I think any of us had anticipated I
had hoped to be able to file a l bill um
in the Senate but there was no agreement
so we decided after the you know time
was getting nigh in late February to
violate Bill to propose an amendment to
a house bill have a public hearing and
um bring it to the house hoping that
there was going to be a settlement
between the Attorney General's office
and the hospital Association so I think
a lot of people work diligently
certainly the governor did Henry Lipman
the State Medicaid director did the
hospital Association Steve Onan did uh
the Attorney General's office did and I
think agreed on basic parameters but not
all parameters and so it went to a
public hearing um in the
Senate and we adopted an amendment that
you see before you is the Senate passed
version of the bill so that's what's
happen happens um had we
had the opportunity to file a late bill
with something ready to go um you folks
in the house would have had the
opportunity to have a public hearing it
just unfortunately because these are
complicated
issues um it's been subject the Met tax
has been subject to litigation in the
past the state has lost that litigation
and you know I'm happy to provide the
2014 Superior Court decision one two
three four five I think Jess already had
it I gave it to him I if if this is the
only copy I can uh no no no I I have
other copies I think I gave one to Erica
too okay so thank you um there's been a
litigation on this in the past and if I
can try in the simplest terms to
summarize the litigation
um the Medicaid enhancement tax is
levied on net patient revenue of
hospitals so that includes both
outpatient and inpatient
Services the reason the tax which raises
about $320 million of revenue for the
State of New Hampshire has been found
unconstitutional is that identical
services that are offered by other
providers similar to hospitals but not
hospitals for instance could be an
Ambulatory Surgery Center it could be um
Physical Therapy it could be any number
of other exact identical Services is not
subject to um the Medicaid enhancement
tax so I think the
conclusion
of the court in
2014 was that the tax was
unconstitutional so my my understanding
is there have been two settlements that
the state has entered into and the
latest settlement which um returns 91%
of the generated Revenue back to the
hospitals for distribution to the 26
Hospital
members that settlement expires
in a month or less and so the need for
legislation and again that's the process
apologies to our friends in the house
that you haven't had a chance to really
vet this as well as we have although we
also didn't have a lot of time to vet it
but this amendment this bill um with the
Senate Amendment did have a public
Hearing in Senator Gray's finance
committee representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair and and thank you for
that uh summary Senator I'm I'm glad
that I've had the opportunity to talk
with you and others about this bill in
the last 72 hours and what I what I
think I I I I I see fairly clearly the
complicating issue for the House
Representatives here is that that this
could be the greatest bill ever and it
never saw a single meeting or
conversation amongst house members and
and so the the effective request of this
Committee of conference is to get four
out of 400 house members to agree to the
good work of the Senate and that's a
huge responsibility if we were to accept
it um and as I've slept on it a couple
of nights I think where I've come to to
to to fall is
that for us for us 1centers to speak for
the
400 I think what we need to do is to
make sure that what we're doing is
really right and vital And
Timely uh be conf confident in what we
do and also to be as minimalistic as we
can so that we don't overrun our you
know lean over our skis too far and take
on more than what we should I think I
think we need to be conservative in this
Committee of conference about what the
house position can be because we haven't
had a proper opportunity to develop a
house position and and I know all the
good work you've done with all the
people I know how difficult this is I
really respect that whole process of
yours but um but I'm just letting you
know that I you know although I I'm
generally in support of of the need to
do this I I'm I just want to I
personally will be wanting to be
cautious about how much we take
on and and I totally appreciate it and
it's really nobody's fault um that we
are here
on June 6 at the deadline of Committee
of conference this is complicated it's
contentious it's been subject to
litigation a lot of money is at stake um
the viability of hospitals is at stake
the impact on the general fund um and
the state of New Hampshire for revenues
is at stake and at the end of the day
our health care System I think is at
stake and so um I couldn't agree with
you more representative Edwards that it
would have been
um helpful had we had more time to vet
this I
totally understand it so if I could Mr
chair um maybe walk through the
amendment and try to hit the the
highlights of it yes please all right
so I'm assuming because the house does
such a great job of side by sides that
there are side by
sides okay well I'll I'll do my best
then I'll be bouncing back and forth
between the amendment and and the
um
um underlying Senate bills so
the first part of the bill is the
underlying bill so really the hospital
piece starts on page two line 8 where um
there's a definition of hospitals and
Hospital Medicaid payments that's
section two and three okay so
that's my understanding that's
recreating um language that was in a
previous settlement so really no change
is my understanding and Henry can
correct me if I'm wrong on that but
that's my understanding so in the Senate
version in order to mitigate the impact
on
hospitals um we moved the 91% which is
the current rate of dollars flowing back
to the hospital from the Met tax um to
93% but um that was deemed unacceptable
to you know all the parties that or at
least some of the parties that worked
all winter and spring on it so the first
change in the amendment is to go back to
91% so if you're looking at the
amendment it's on line five if you're
looking at the bill it's line 29 so 91
becomes 93 and so just think of it this
way that um every 1% of $300 million is
about $3 million okay so it it reverts
$6 million back to um the
state one of the things that is being
proposed here both in the bill and I
think this is important so if you go to
the bill on page two on the bottom of
page two there is language that gives
the commissioner of the Department of
Health and Human Services the authority
to determine method or methods used to
make Medicaid payments subject to um
Medicaid reimbursement and obviously it
has to be approved by the center for
Medicaid and Medicare
Services um but the Hope in doing this
is to move away from the current
structure into what's known as more
directed payments by going to directed
payments we take advantage of the 9010
match um under Medicaid expansion and
that increases Revenue um for the state
okay but when you do that there are
hospitals that are in different places
in terms
of their cost structure so whether it's
the Acuity level of patients whether
it's
um the uncompensated care level of
patients the number of patients that
have insurance all of those things
factor
into
[Music]
um that 91% going back so it fluctuates
from year to year the point of allowing
this language now is to take advantage
of better reimburse ment rates which
means a win-win for the state and um
mitigating the impact of 91% on
hospitals because remember they pay a
tax but they get 91% back and it's
allocated amongst the hospitals the 91%
based on this patient mix and Acuity
level so that is kind of outlined in
page two section three and it gives oh
I'm so sorry I've gotten ahead of myself
no one has the amendment I have them
here
somewhere thought they had been provided
thank you jimy my
apologies
take just all right
so then moving on to page three it
outlines sort of the bottom of page two
and Page Three what the parameters of
how this Authority is given to the
commissioner and this is pretty
important in determining which method to
utilize the commissioner shall seek to
prevent to the greatest extent
possible year-over-year Hospital
reimbursement reductions in the
aggregate while at the same time
achieving the highest available Federal
match so that's the goal of everything
that is trying to be done okay so then
the rest of Page Three is largely
boilerplate that
um is consistent with the existing
settlement with the hospitals okay so
then moving on to page four the next big
chain
in the
amendment is that we move
from um 7% which is line 20 of the bill
to 9% which is line 14 of the amendment
and that gets back to the 91% so
9% then gets funneled into other health
care services
okay so that is consistent with the
position that you know the Attorney
General's office took as to what the um
ultimate disposition of the settlement
should look
like next change is and this is the
critical change that I hope that we can
buy into but I'm not suggesting that the
Attorney General's office or the
governor's office is fully supportive
of um
top of page five in the bill versus um
lines
23 on the amendment section 13 and 14 so
there would be a directed payment of $57
million of State funds to mitigate the
losses that the hospitals will
experience some hospitals are going to
do better than today based on their
patient mix but some won't and that's
just a factor of trying to maximize
state revenue and move away from the
dish portion of how we've distributed
this Revenue which by the way is a CMS
and federal requirement at this point to
be moving away so we get the advantage
of more revenue and we're more in
compliance with um Federal
rules so we make this $
5.72
million payment that is matched by I
believe it's $8.6
million to of federal funds to create a
$4.3
million
um additional help if you will for the
hospitals to mitigate against the red
ink that many of them will experience
without that $14.3 million there still
and I believe this spreadsheet has been
shared with folks but if not we'll make
sure it
is um even after this $14.3
million there are still several
hospitals that um will be in the red
Visa
their um payment from previous years to
what's anticipated in future years now
these are all subject to audit and
change from year to year again depending
on your patient Acuity but the hospitals
while they're not thrilled about this
have have agreed that this is um
something that they can accept and live
with even despite the fact that six
hospitals um have red
ink the generated net revenue is anticip
at and this is the last thing on the
amendment it's the statement of intent
on line four that as a result of all of
this the state will net $22 million of
um new Revenue both $
million of Medicaid enhancement tax
revenue which then gets matched so well
no one's happy with this certainly the
hospitals aren't certainly I think the
folks that negotiated this are not it's
still I think a rational way to proceed
because and this and then I'll stop
after this Mr chair I think if you look
at and I believe I passed out the
2014 court case it's pretty clear to me
when I read this
that the Met tax has been held to be
unconstitutional
because it applies the same taxes
doesn't apply excuse me the same tax for
exact same Services it does apply to
hospitals it doesn't apply to other
service providers and as such has been
ruled unconstitutional so in the
absence of an agreement or acquiescence
on the part of the hospitals to pay the
tax there's likely to be
litigation what is the impact of
litigation I think no one
knows and
um I would say I I'm certainly not going
to be here next year but most of you
will and if there's litigation that puts
into
doubt um $320 is Million Dollar of
general fund Revenue to the state I
would argue that that's
um not a good way to proceed which for
the
relatively small cost of $ 5.72 million
matched by $8.6 million of federal
revenue makes this a rational way to
proceed representative
stram uh thank you for all that um
representing I guess the house side and
following uh on both your comments and U
uh chairman Edwards uh you know kind of
our experience um with the hospitals as
part of the budget uh process uh was
pretty positive we were brought brought
forward u a certain fixed amount of
money to deal with Medicaid rate
increases and uh we're we're challenged
with the uh exercise of Prior
prioritizing uh Services over another uh
in a way that might uh improve the
overall effectiveness of the Health Care
System uh the hospital Association uh uh
kicked us off by saying you know what
don't give us
anything uh we have problems with
patients being stuck in emergency rooms
and and in the hospitals and we can't
get them out if you can prioritize in
the money in a way that gets uh provides
places for uh those people to go you're
going to help us and it's going to help
the whole system and uh uh that really
uh started the ball rolling for us in in
what was part of the What's called the
miracle budget and uh in prioritizing
nursing homes and at home care uh and uh
really taking a look at every every one
of the um uh Medicaid uh programs uh and
even with the final 40 million that uh
came available in the last 24 hours
before before the budget uh passed with
a gavel in the house there was still no
money for the hospitals so um uh and you
know not having experience
um you know with this particular
Amendment here uh you know we come in
with a mindset that uh uh that that the
uh hospitals uh uh Representatives here
are uh if they're if they're asking uh
for for funds and and change in way to
do things that uh we're going to listen
very very hard based on the experience
that we had uh in this two years uh and
um you know in terms of your uh
presentation of the amendment
uh you know seeing the uh previous 93%
being brought down to
91% uh the uh uh the emphasis on um
services that uh would be eligible for
the 9010 uh Federal match instead of a
50/50 match and uh a relatively um uh
you not insignificant but one that
multiplies uh additional appropriation
from the general funds um
I'm very very inclined to uh support
this amendment um as as you um presented
it here but I'm also eager to hear from
those who have spent more time uh on the
the met and the dish payments as well
thanks
Senator thank you very much Mr
chairman um I have been serving on
finance committee through both prior
settlements
and um I guess I should say that we
can't just if we don't go forward with
this we can't just extend the life of
the settlement that's running out in
three weeks because the federal rules
around dish payments have changed so
that's really not an option for us and I
think the Constitution
ality
is is a real thing we changed the
statute to fix the Constitutional
problem back I think either in 2016 or
18 and at that time maybe it was 18 the
hospitals acknowledged that the statute
was
constitutional so it got us out of
ongoing expensive with
litigation and um I think that that
background I hope will be
helpful representive Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair I I just want to in
introduce the handout that came out
while uh while they're speaking taking
place um this I I I thought of this when
I heard Senator Bradley mentioned how
good the LBA is at doing side by sides
and so so uh I had asked the division 3
LBA to put together a side by side of
the current law versus what the Senate
proposal was because you know coming new
to this what the Viewpoint I needed was
to see what what are what our current
law is and what are we proposing to do
to change it and I I'm bringing this to
you way too late in the process and it
may not have any practical use but um
but I I did did want to make it
available to just let um Senator Bradley
know that there was some effort by the
LBA to do a side by
side and and I should have distributed
it sooner that that that's on me
representative L um thank you Mr
chairman as somebody not on house
finance I have uh put on my scho big
year and delve deep into these numbers
to understand them but numbers are
something I have some experience with um
I'm trying to understand how the
91% plus um these additional funds
really translate because if we look at
the
5.72% that's approximately another 2%
but I'm trying to understand how we are
able to have the
143 million additional and how we can
sort of compare apples and oranges on
that because I don't quite understand
applying the state portion of the Met um
versus applying the Met plus some of the
Federal match to this I'm just trying to
make sure that I fully understand what
it is that we're trying to consider here
with his additional
funds not at
all step up please state your name and
position good morning for the record
Henry Litman the state's Medicaid
director um thank you for the question
representative Leon um
the the 91% of the Medicaid enhancement
tax comes in and as uh Senator Bradley
talked about that that um the the
current law if you will and the proposal
sort of do the same thing in the sense
that um we look to maximize what the
state will have for money to work with
and to to um provide relief to the
hospitals for the
uncompensated um care and um other costs
that they incur and serving the program
with respect to
um the um the 5.72 million um that is
additional um funds that um otherwise
would just be used in the the state
program if you will um on the state side
and because
the multiplier on the federal match if
you kind of think about it kind of
Simply if if it were 6 million under the
normal match it would just be we'd get
12 million out of it and because there's
an enhanced match available under the
directed payments we're able to um get
that up to
14.3 uh okay um that's helpful so
generally that means that um on the rest
of the match on the others that that's
what's supporting our other areas of
Medical Care such as um these ones where
we're discharging people um I'm just I'm
trying to understand why I should look
at this as 91.5 point7 looking at it as
a total of uh 20 uh 296 million and not
look at it as closer to 305 million
which is the amount that's being
distributed within within um the
handouts that we have here I mean I
think that the amount of money that gets
paid out would be the the
29.4 plus the 14.3 to the hospitals but
in terms of what it costs the state in
terms of funds that it is putting into
the program would be an additional
5.72 representative
Edwards uh thank you uh Mr chair um M Mr
Litman this this may not be the
appropriate question for you so if if
the the Senate wanted to respond that
that's fine with me um the the 5.72
Million number I've been thinking about
that wondering how we came to
5.72 and it strikes me that we have
essentially a we're all in violent
agreement that 91% of the Met tax that
comes in should be redistributed
appropriately to balance out the
hospitals uh and that left the 9% to to
be um reprogrammed and it it strikes me
that 5.72 gets close to being 2% of the
total met tax and it just makes me
wonder if this five if this
5.72 isn't really just another way to
rename it to bring us back to
93% and if that's the if that's what
happened then I don't think that's I I I
don't perceive that to be acceptable to
the governor
at all so so I I'm just curious about
how we pulled 5.72 out because that's a
pretty precise
number and if the Senate wants to speak
to it first I
can so I think in terms of you know as
the sen Senator Bradley talked about
there's a lot of time spent in terms of
how can we take the money in and make
payments in a way that is um if you will
um has a lesser impact on on the uh on
the hospitals and the maximized impact
for the state I think when um 91% in the
Senate discussions when 91% was a
position that the hospitals weren't
supporting there was um what else was
available to be able to um if you will
and in what forms we could pay it out
that would would lead to that to smooth
out the the red um further and I think
that's basically the the number it's
also important to point out it's it's
for four years and it's a constant
amount for each of the four years so as
the tax grows that will become a smaller
and smaller
percentage follow it okay so I know
you're in an awkward position so I I
what I'm hearing is that the
5.72% is a another way of renaming some
of the uh contribution being made to get
us close to 93% by way of a a different
vehicle but the same
destination I think it is adding money
to the 91% I think it's the simplest way
to say I don't think there was any um I
mean I think the reason it's in the way
it is is to be explicit of where the
money's coming from um the actually the
that particular model worked better for
the hospitals than the straight 93% that
was in the original version that's
that's why it came out that way um you
know my role in this process has not
been as a negotiator it's been to
provide information to the
parties representative L um thank you Mr
chairman um this may be a naive question
but when I look at the 13 uh 3192
million collected and then the 305
million paid out to me that looks like a
return rate of 95 a. half% can you tell
me how I'm wrong in that interpretation
because looking at the numbers that's
what makes sense but I I have have to be
missing something here I I think in
terms of your math in terms of um that's
not necessarily um wrong when you add
the two together um but um it it may not
be 95.2 but it's it's a higher number
than 91 let's put it that
way
Senator good
Henry um because all these funds that
are collected by the that are restricted
funds and must be spent on Medicaid
provider
payments don't the
hospitals because of their size and the
amount of Medicaid services they deliver
already get above
91% of the metb back in a way through
provider payments
um because they do the most
Medicaid so I guess the the payment
stream to hospital is what what comes
out of this plus the the regular
payments which uh representative
Stringham was talking about um for the
larger hospitals I think generally not
just in New Hampshire but everywhere
that um Medicaid um when you count all
the cost all the payments that they get
together is typically no higher than
Medicare and typically some what less
than Medicare you know could be as much
as 20% or more for some hospitals less
so it's the payments together trying to
bring them up to uh an adequacy um you
know and the the sort of the CMS
Benchmark is to get hospitals under
Medicaid between 80 and 100% of
Medicare could I follow please yes and
with directed
payments in addition to getting around a
60%
Federal match versus 50 doesn't
CMS either allow or require some quality
metrics yes um that would be helpful for
the state yeah the directed payments uh
do come with accountability and that's
also a provision in the bill that um
that the directed payments have to come
with a set of of quality metrics to try
to lift up the performance of the system
and um you know in the bill there's um
the responsibility to meet those metrics
you know fall in the hospitals and
that's um you know something that has to
be those metrics have to be developed in
state and then approved um by
CMS Senator Bradley uh yeah I I just
want to make clear that the 5.72 is not
general fund Revenue it's coming from um
the the Met revenue and and that because
of the enhanced match um of the 8.6 it's
actually right it's it's actually better
and at the end of the day it's what I
think the hospitals can acquest to and
we're not litigating
potentially um you know this issue and
throwing you know the metx
constitutionality back into question and
the impact that that has on future
budget so I I think
that if there's a disagreement between
some of the parties that's what it's
over and it's a a relatively in the
overall scheme of things and the
importance to the state and to the
hospitals and patient care and New
Hampshire I think it's a pretty small
amount hopefully that we can agree
to I think the time has come for me to
return the favor and explain the process
by which I came to the opinion I have
today so I was thrown at this very late
in the
process normally something like this
especially a $5.7 million allocation
would go through our health and human
services committee if it succeeded there
it would then go to finance where a lot
of it's the largest committee a lot of
very smart people would have worked on
that and probably answered ahead of time
most of the questions that we have today
I have have received um I don't want to
say threats but hardcore opinions I'll
veto if this will sue if that um it's
because I am new to this Arena and
people don't know me I doesn't help um
cuz the house position began at a hard
no there were questions about doing it
this way where I had to make sure we
weren't even going to violate House
Rules by receiving the report if there
was one our beginning position was no
instead of making a long protracted
negotiation I I met with Senator Bradley
and said you know what fine we'll do the
91% and the other change to nine at that
point probably my fault I had no idea
that this $5.7 million was included I
then got questions about was that just
gaming it to get the 93 that were
negotiating down to 91 there is not time
to do this properly so
I think that we're being very
magnanimous when the house position is
we'll do the
91% the 9% but not the 5.7 million and
um can keep telling me about lawsuits
and my response is going to be everybody
knew this deadline was coming why didn't
you start working earlier so that it
could have gone through the proper
process and maybe I'd be sitting here
with a smile and yes today but that's
not what happened um so I'm sorry
Senator Bradley but that's the house
position say that's unfortunate um but I
respect the house and uh respect that
you can't get to
yes I think at this point we'll just
close the committee of conference on
1593 okay
oh
e
e e
okay we'll reconvene actually we just
come back from our break one more time
on Bill
11:27 um I guess just as a summary of
what happened at 9:00 uh we were we went
into recess on Tuesday
awaiting uh leak legal opinion at the
request of Senator Bradley um and we
received somewhat of a description of
what the problems were
although I was hoping the attorney would
be here again so he could actually try
again at explaining to everybody what
the problems are so now we've agreed to
take another break and we are here
supposedly to see a
solution to the problems that the
attorney
has um or obser ered so do we have any
communication from him thank you Mr
chairman um no so at this point the
Senate will aced to the house position
where you're going to remove Senate Bill
385 58 358 from the bill and we will
move forward with the uh underlying Bill
okay thank you for that the motion the
motion still is there but before we do
take the uh the vote uh I just want
everybody to be clear that I certainly
am in support of what 358 attempted to
do uh but I've got issues with it the
way it was it seems the Senate isn't
didn't like my first amendment we can't
seem to find a solution uh in a timely
fashion so with uh remorse I am going to
vote for the motion on the floor which
is to remove 358
language um the motion was we we exceed
to the Senate position with the further
amendment of removing that language
anybody else care to speak before we do
our
vote seeing none house members all in
favor
okay and you are as well so I guess that
concludes our business on House Bill
1127 thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman and thank you to house members
as
well
e
e e
good afternoon everybody I am going to
call to order the what is this the like
we recessed yesterday yeah we're just
going to um conference okay um opening
the committee of conference for House
Bill
318 and I will be taking a short recess
while we or a short break while we all
have a chance to read the amendment that
we were just
given
e
e e
okay was it in there
and that's already in there it's already
a it's it's
already
okay all right I'm reopening the um
Committee of conference on House Bill
318 and with that I believe that um we
have come to the final agreement there
is one change that last second change we
are going to be making and that is um on
page five of the well I'm not even sure
if this is the bill or not I'm just
using the thing you guys gave me um
anyway the language will be right now it
says the court shall have the authority
under paragraph one to set cash a
corporate charity Bill if the court
finds the defendant is in the court may
only set cash bail corporate security
amount in the amount that defendant's
able to make we're striking the part
that ISS the defendant is found inent
it's just going to say the court may
only set cash bail corporate security
amount and the amount the defendant is
able to make in other words so that cash
bail is not used to hold someone um for
the purpose of holding them cash Ba's
intent is to make sure that someone
shows up for court not to hold them so
they can't come back um does everyone
here agree with that yes Mr chairman and
just for anybody watching so on the
draft amendment that we have before us
it's on page four line 11 m on Amendment
page4
line1 yes and that has been sent to alls
so what I I propose is each member we
going to vote y or nay and we're going
to vote with the intent that that is on
the document we're going to sign
downstairs LS does everyone agree with
that just crossing out the IND
if the court find no this is going to be
strict if the court finds the defendant
engent it's going to say the court may
only set cash bill is that okay okay all
right with that everything else we are
okay with so um I'm going to call um
call a vote so I would ask uh
representative Murray yes or no yes
representative har G yes representative
rhods yes uh Senator Bradley yes Senator
Carson yes Senator Susi yes and the
chair votes yes with that agreement um
we have an accord and we will all go
downstairs and sign it when ready SE uh
Senator Bradley so for those of us in
the Senate this has been a long hard
fight but I want to compliment the four
of you and the work that you have done
over the summer um to bring parties
together I mean you guys have done an
unbelievable job and I think you know
Senator sus is sponsored this
legislation in the past I've sponsored
this legislation in the past Senator
Carson has heard this legislation in the
past the four of you are getting the
ball in the end zone so bless you thank
you uh we really appreciate the
acknowledgement and we could not have
done it without our Senate partners and
I don't want to forget to mention that
in the audience we have um um another
senator who happened to sponsor this a
couple times as well um Senator Daryl
abbis from Salem so thank you all very
much and we are so happy to have been
able to do this for the people of New
Hampshire and um we are all hopeful that
we do not hear the word bail again for a
couple years
anyway with that we are adjourned thank
you well
done yeah we have a 130 here anyone else
um you just got to wait at OLS
now
e
e e
okay I'm opening the committee of
conference uh reopening committee
conference oh where did Jeb go Senator
Bradley that's all right okay so I've
reopened a committee of conference on
House Bill
1292 um no changes have been made I
don't believe from last night um and we
are are ready to vote on it as is with
amendment number
2258 H does everyone have a copy of
that okay and with that um
representative Muse has been replaced on
the committee by representative Smith
for the record and representative Smith
is not able to make it but he will be
making the necessary sign off um so with
that I'm going to call the role unless
someone wants to make any further
discussion no um we we already went over
this yesterday it um this adds to the
original Bill the sanctuary City bill
that was passed by the Senate and tabled
in the house um so with that um I would
ask representative Manion to vote Yes or
No Yes representative Manion votes yes
representative um rhs yes
um Senator Bradley yes I'm sorry Senator
your name Senator birdsill and um
Senator Carson yes and the chair votes
yes uh unanimous and
this you voted yes she did yeah um and
with
that thank you I wouldn't be able to do
anything without her cuz I would just be
like passing stuff
nobody voted on um all right with that
we will send this off to OS for
Signature and ijin the
hearing you as well thank you